La Bible
La Bible, elle est très connue d'abord comme un livre, mais nous croyons que c'est beaucoup plus que ça.
Et nous allons vivre ce mois de février en train de parler de ça.
Parfois ça peut paraître très très basique, c'est ce que je vais dire, et c'est juste avant pour ça que je vais dire.
Parce qu'il y a des choses, au moins avec moi, je ne sais pas si chez vous c'est pareil, mais avec moi,
il y a des choses très très basiques que je dois toujours me rappeler pour que je les fasse.
Parce que sinon, ça ne marche pas.
Et nous allons vivre tout le mois de février en train de partager sur la Bible.
En fait, c'est un parcours.
L'année dernière, pour ceux qui étaient déjà là, on a parlé sur la recherche du bonheur.
Et juste après, on a parlé sur l'amour, qui c'est une des façons, on a plus le temps, en fait, de rechercher, de vivre le bonheur.
Et là, on parle, on va parler de la Bible, comme un livre, mais ce n'est pas tout à fait un simple livre.
C'est ça qu'on va partager sur moi.
Et je vais vous expliquer comment on va vivre ça.
D'abord, si on parle de bonheur, si on parle de plaisir, il faut savoir que la vie chrétienne, le plaisir chrétien,
malheureusement, il y a plusieurs personnes qui pensent comme ça et aussi qui prêchent comme ça.
Et moi, je suis toujours, j'ai déjà dit ça ici et je vais toujours le dire.
Mais le plaisir chrétien, il est bien conscient qu'un jour avec Jésus n'est pas forcément mieux que le jour précédent.
Un jour avec Jésus, le lendemain avec Jésus, il n'est pas forcément mieux qu'aujourd'hui avec Jésus.
Je m'explique.
La vie chrétienne, elle n'est pas toujours belle.
Elle n'est pas toujours à 100% agréable.
Et plus on connaît Jésus, ça ne veut pas forcément dire que plus notre vie, elle sera joyeuse dans le sens superficiel de Dieu.
Non.
Il faut d'abord savoir ça pour commencer à parler de la Bible et aussi pour savoir quelle est l'importance de la Bible dans nos vies.
Par exemple, on va lire un texte aujourd'hui, c'est juste un verset.
Si vous avez envie d'ouvrir, si vous avez une Bible, ça se trouve au milieu de la Bible, au livre de Psalme, chapitre 19, verset 8.
Je vais lire direct parce que c'est juste un verset.
La loi de l'éternel est parfaite.
Elle restaure l'âme.
Encore une fois, je vais lire.
La loi de l'éternel, elle est parfaite.
Elle restaure l'âme.
La Bible, elle part de la...
Quand on lit la Bible, les auteurs en train d'écrire sur la Bible, ils parlent de la loi de l'éternel.
C'est un peu la même chose.
Ça veut dire la Bible, elle est parfaite.
Elle restaure l'âme.
Alors, d'abord, si on a un verset comme celui-là dans la Bible, c'est déjà la raison que me montre que la vie chrétienne, elle a certains soucis.
C'est pas parce que nous sommes chrétiens qu'ils nous sommes toujours à « Ouais, c'est la vie du monde, on va faire la fête, on va lever nos bras, on va taper nos mains parce que Jésus... »
Non.
Nous croyons vraiment que Jésus, il est la raison de tout ça.
Nous croyons vraiment que Jésus, il est la solution de tout ça.
Mais si la Bible, elle nous dit que la parole, la loi de l'éternel est parfaite et elle restaure l'âme, ça veut dire que parfois, notre âme a besoin d'être restaurée.
Ça veut dire que parfois, la vie, elle n'est pas facile.
Et David, il a écrit plusieurs chapitres du livre de Psaume et plusieurs fois, il dit la même chose.
Il y a un chapitre très connu, le chapitre 23.
Parmi les chrétiens, il est très connu.
Et il dit toujours la même chose.
Au milieu du chapitre, il dit « Il restaure mon âme. »
« Il me conduit dans le sentier de la justice. »
« Il restaure mon âme. »
Ça veut dire encore une fois qu'il y a des moments difficiles.
Et si vous connaissez un peu l'histoire de David, si vous ne la connaissez pas, je vous encourage à essayer de la connaître.
Mais si vous connaissez l'histoire de David, vous allez voir qu'effectivement, il a eu besoin, pendant plusieurs fois dans sa vie, d'avoir son âme en train de se faire restaurer.
Alors, ou dans un autre cadre, nous croyons en tant que chrétiens, nous croyons que Dieu existe et que le diable existe aussi.
Et nous croyons qu'il a la joie, le bonheur que nous sommes en train de gagner, de vivre avec Dieu.
Le diable, il va essayer toujours de voler ça de nous.
Et dans ce moment, comme je viens de dire, peut-être que la vie, elle sera un peu plus dure.
Et dans ce moment de tristesse, parce que nous l'avons tous, nous avons besoin de quelque chose.
Nous avons besoin d'une chose concrète, d'une chose pertinente, et d'une chose qui puisse devenir un peu comme l'essence pour nous.
Et je ne sais pas quel est votre essence.
Il y a des personnes qui sont un peu à diesel, ça mettra un peu de temps pour démarrer, et après il démarre, et voilà.
Moi, c'est un peu comme ça.
Il y a des personnes qui sont vraiment speedées à 100%, à 200%, comme des voitures de Formule 1.
L'accélération, elle est vraiment de 0 à 10 secondes, il faut en 300 km heure.
Je ne sais pas comment ça se passe chez vous, mais nous tous, même les voitures de course, elles ont besoin d'une essence.
Et c'est drôle parce que nous trouvons partout des essences, surtout quand nous sommes tristes.
Nous trouvons des livres de, comment ça se dit en français, de l'auto-aide, c'est ça ?
Ça se dit ça en français ?
Hein ?
Développement personnel, je ne sais pas.
Auto-aide, ça ne se dit pas du tout.
Alors, ce n'est pas ça.
Bon, les livres qui vont nous aider à vivre une vie un peu mieux, c'est développement personnel.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Voilà, c'est bien.
Bon, on cherche des livres comme ça, ils ne sont pas mauvais.
Ils sont, peut-être qu'on va trouver des bons livres.
On cherche des...
Moi, j'ai une amie qui a vécu une situation très, très difficile, très dure au Brésil.
Et après ça, elle m'a dit qu'elle est devenue la personne qui connaît le plus les films du cinéma.
Elle part au cinéma presque tous les jours pour voir des bons films du cinéma.
Elle a cherché dans le cinéma la raison de l'essence qui commence à la conduire,
qui commence à la faire sortir de ce chemin très, très dur qu'elle est en train de vivre.
Et pourquoi pas penser à la Bible ?
C'est vrai que ça a l'air très basique, surtout pour les chrétiens,
mais la Bible, elle a une valeur très, très, très importante dans ce jeu.
Et si nous allons dédier un mois, et c'est très beau, un mois, pour parler de la Bible,
c'est parce que nous croyons que c'est vraiment le guide, le mode d'emploi,
la façon de vivre en tant que chrétien, elle se trouve dans la Bible.
Tous les pasteurs, tous les prédicateurs, toutes les personnes sont en train de parler de Dieu,
de Jésus, et surtout, de Jésus surtout.
Toutes ces personnes, si elles sont en train de parler une chose concrète,
cette chose doit se trouver dans la Bible.
Si elle n'est pas écrite dans la Bible, on peut se doter, on peut se méfier un tout petit peu.
Parce que la Bible, pour nous, c'est vraiment quelque chose d'important.
C'est vraiment quelque chose de singulier.
Et je vous dis, on va vivre ce mois en train de parler de la Bible,
parce que, alors que nous, surtout les chrétiens, nous connaissons un peu tout ça,
parfois on a du mal à prendre nos Bibles et commencer à la lire.
J'étais avec Jonathan tout à l'heure, il est venu avec un livre en me disant,
mais ça, c'était formidable. Pourquoi?
Parce que c'était une personne en train d'écrire sur la Bible.
Et ça, c'est tellement important.
Parfois, on essaie d'obliger les personnes à faire des choses.
Moi, d'abord, je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui aime être obligé de faire quoi que ce soit.
Quand quelqu'un m'oblige à faire quelque chose,
j'ai déjà un certain côté révolutionnaire chez moi,
qui me fait, ah non, c'est obligatoire, ce n'est pas pour moi.
Moi, si je suis comme ça, et peut-être que vous aussi,
l'obligation, elle est plutôt mauvaise pour moi.
Et plusieurs fois, on pense qu'on est obligé de lire la Bible,
parce que je suis chrétien, mais c'est bien le contraire.
C'est bien le contraire.
Le même livre d'Épistole, mais on va voir plusieurs choses après,
il nous dit une chose très profonde,
jusqu'au départ de ce livre, chapitre 1,
il nous dit que l'homme qui trouve son plaisir dans la loi de l'Éternel,
dans la Bible, il est semblable à plusieurs choses,
ce qui est des bonnes choses.
Alors, si nous sommes en train d'établir une Église,
de vivre une communauté,
cette communauté doit être basée sur la Bible.
Et on va vivre ce mois, en train de parler de ça.
Comment on va vivre ce mois ?
On va diviser ce mois en trois parties,
et on va partager ça pendant cette série.
La première, ça commence aujourd'hui.
Il faut savoir pourquoi nous acceptons la Bible
comme la parole de Dieu.
Il faut se poser cette question.
Moi, je suis quelqu'un qui aime poser des questions.
Moi, je suis quelqu'un qui aime les questions.
J'étais quelqu'un à l'école que,
j'étais pas, mon cahier, il était pas complet,
j'étais pas quelqu'un qui aimait faire le devoir à la maison.
Ça, c'était pas moi.
Par contre, à l'école, j'ai posé plein de questions.
Parce que pour moi, dans ma tête,
c'était à l'école le moment d'apprendre,
et après à la maison, c'était le moment de jouer.
Je n'aimais pas d'autre étudier à la maison.
Ne faites pas ça, hein.
Ça, c'était moi.
C'est pas un bon exemple sur ça.
Mais à l'école, j'ai posé plein de questions.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on va se poser certaines questions,
c'est moi.
On va parler de la Bible, mais d'une façon très honnête,
très claire.
Nous sommes des adultes.
Et nous sommes des personnes que, au moins moi,
nous n'aimons pas être...
Nous n'aimons pas que les personnes nous cachent des choses.
Et là, nous allons d'abord nous poser cette question officiellement.
Mais même en plus,
je sais pas si vous êtes au courant,
cette semaine, nous avons commencé nos groupes de maison.
Nous avons lancé cinq groupes de maison.
C'était super.
J'ai eu des échos,
chez nous en tout cas.
C'était vraiment, vraiment bien.
Et je vous invite à en faire partie.
C'est pas une programmation,
c'est pas encore une activité de l'Église.
Pour moi, c'est l'activité de notre Église.
C'est un moment tellement bien,
tellement agréable,
tellement profond.
Je vous encourage à faire partie de ça.
Et pendant nos groupes de maison de ce mois,
nous allons parler de ça aussi.
Nous allons avoir la possibilité de nous poser des questions.
La deuxième chose,
nous allons voir les avantages,
le bénéfice et le pouvoir
que la Bible a
et comment elle peut nous nourrir.
Et la troisième chose,
il faut entendre aussi,
en des vies très pratiques,
qui puisse provoquer une augmentation
de la lecture de la Bible.
On va essayer de devenir très, très pratique
à la fin du mois,
pour que nous tous,
moi, je suis inclus dans cette « nous tous »,
pour qu'on puisse comprendre
l'importance de connaître,
de lire et de vivre un parcours avec la Bible.
Alors, pour commencer,
d'abord, il faut savoir pourquoi nous l'acceptons
comme un livre puissant.
Et là, je vais essayer de...
J'ai déjà me posé ces questions,
c'est pour ça que je les partage.
Je vais essayer de poser les trois questions
que je fais pour moi-même,
entre nous, entre amis.
La première question,
et vous allez...
C'est un pasteur qui se pose cette question.
Oui, ça, c'est absolument nécessaire.
La première question,
avant même de parler de la Bible,
est-ce que Dieu, il existe ?
Ça, c'est une question très importante.
Et si on ne se pose pas de questions comme ça,
on peut arriver à avoir beaucoup de choses,
de la bonne musique,
de la bonne ambiance dans une église,
mais on sera là juste pour faire encore une personne en plus.
Mais ça, ce n'est pas le but, en fait.
Nous allons commencer par le niveau,
à mon avis, le plus basique,
mais pas dans le mauvais sens,
mais dans le sens du premier niveau,
on va dire comme ça,
de la foi.
Si nous ne croyons pas que Dieu existe,
tout le reste,
il est un peu abîmé.
Et là, la première question qu'on doit se poser,
c'est, est-ce que je crois à ça ?
Et moi, je me suis posé cette question.
Et là, ma réponse, c'était,
oui, je crois.
Mais ce n'est pas assez simple.
Et là, comme je suis quelqu'un d'essayer
de voir très clairement les choses,
j'ai commencé à chercher parmi mon histoire,
parmi mon parcours,
pourquoi je crois.
Alors, socialement,
c'est assez simple de voir.
J'ai plusieurs raisons d'y croire.
Je suis né dans une famille chrétienne.
Mes parents, ils étaient chrétiens.
Mes grands-parents, ils étaient chrétiens.
Mon père, ma mère, ils étaient chrétiens.
Et je suis né dans un contexte très, très chrétien,
officiellement.
D'accord ? C'est bien.
Et après, j'ai vécu toute ma vie
en train d'aller dans une église ou autre.
Avec mon père, avec ma mère,
en train d'écouter la parole de Dieu.
D'accord ?
Et là, socialement,
et c'est toujours comme ça,
socialement, nous avons une raison.
Si nous commençons à chercher,
si vous êtes comme moi,
toujours en train de chercher la raison des choses,
parce que moi, je suis comme ça,
socialement, il y a peut-être une raison
qui montre pourquoi vous êtes dans la situation
que vous êtes aujourd'hui.
Pourquoi vous vous trouvez dans la situation
que vous vous trouvez aujourd'hui.
Il y a toujours, parfois pas,
mais presque toujours,
il y a socialement une explication pour ça.
Ah d'accord ?
Il a pris ce chemin,
il est devenu pasteur,
Gustavo, à cause de ça.
D'accord ?
On peut voir,
socialement,
mon sujet préféré à la fac,
et c'est toujours,
j'ai envie de faire un master sur ça,
c'était l'anthropologie.
Et j'aime bien ça,
c'est les relations humaines,
c'est la sociologie,
l'anthropologie,
ça m'intéressait énormément.
Et je suis comme ça,
c'est dans ma tête,
je viens de rentrer dans ce parcours.
Et peut-être qu'on peut expliquer
plusieurs choses,
socialement,
par niveau.
Par contre,
ça n'explique pas pourquoi je crois
que Dieu existe.
Ça explique les hypothèses,
mais pas la raison.
Et là,
j'ai commencé à chercher
plusieurs choses.
Et c'est clair,
c'est clair,
nous n'allons pas avoir
assez de temps
pour tout dire,
au moins pour dire
tout ce que je pense moi-même.
Mais,
je vais essayer d'être
très, très simpliste,
ça se dit,
simpliste,
et parfois très basique,
mais c'est tellement important,
ça.
C'est tellement important.
C'est pas un message
que je suis en train de prêcher
parce que nous sommes
des nouveaux chrétiens.
Non,
pas du tout ça,
parce que moi,
je pense toujours
que si je suis en train
de prêcher une chose,
c'est parce que moi,
j'ai besoin d'entendre
ces choses.
Alors,
ça veut dire que moi,
je suis pasteur,
j'ai fait mes études
en théologie,
machin,
bref,
et j'ai besoin d'entendre
ces choses.
Et c'est comme ça
qu'on choisit,
moi,
c'est pour ça qu'on choisit,
moi et David,
c'est qu'on va prêcher
à l'église.
Alors,
alors que ça a l'air
très basique,
c'est absolument nécessaire
pour nous
de se poser cette question.
Plusieurs fois,
après avoir eu
ma conversion personnelle,
on va parler de ça
tout à l'heure,
après,
avec mon histoire sociale,
mon parcours
en tant que fils
de chrétien,
machin,
voilà,
plusieurs fois,
je demandais
une chose à Dieu.
C'est la première fois
dans toute ma vie
que je vais partager
cette chose,
même au Brésil,
mes amis,
ils ne sont pas au courant
de ça,
mais plusieurs,
et peut-être que c'est pour ça
que je suis comme ça,
mon caractère,
plusieurs fois,
comme j'étais toujours chrétien,
j'ai posé une question
à Dieu.
Et je ne pense pas
que j'irai aussi,
je ne sais même pas
si ça c'est une réussite
ou pas,
mais j'ai demandé à Dieu
plusieurs fois
de me donner
une journée,
au moins une journée,
avec la tête
d'une personne
complètement non-chrétienne.
J'ai demandé ça,
tu vois,
peut-être que c'est fou,
j'ai demandé ça
parce que,
parfois,
nous les chrétiens,
on commence à vivre
un univers très particulier
et très compliqué,
du coup,
très,
avec nos vocabulaire,
avec nos choses,
avec nos vies,
on parle,
on dit des choses
comme si toutes les personnes
elles sont en train
de nous comprendre.
On parle de Jésus,
des mots qui sont difficiles,
qui se trouvent dans la Bible,
et ça a l'air très facile
pour les chrétiens,
très facile.
Et moi,
j'étais toujours inquiet.
J'étais à l'église,
au Brésil,
je voyais un ami
qui arrivait,
sinon j'étais en train
de partager
avec un ami
qui n'était pas
du tout chrétien
et j'essayais de voir,
mais pourquoi il ne croit pas
et moi je crois,
mais est-ce qu'il faut
voir qu'il y a quelque chose.
Et surtout,
je me demandais,
je me posais la question,
pourquoi il pense ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il doit penser
quand il rentre,
quand il m'entend,
en train de parler
de Dieu,
de la Bible ?
J'étais toujours comme ça
et plusieurs fois,
je me demandais
à Dieu,
j'aimais bien entrer
dans une église
avec une tête
que comme si j'ai...
Je ne sais pas
comment expliquer
cette question,
c'est assez folle
comme question,
drôle aussi,
mais je me demandais,
je me posais cette question
pour essayer
de comprendre.
parce que pour moi,
c'est très important ça.
J'aime mes amis,
j'aime les personnes,
j'aime mes amis chrétiens
et de la même manière,
j'aime mes amis non chrétiens.
Il faut que ça soit comme ça
parmi nous tous.
Et si je crois à tout ça,
comment je vais vivre tout ça
et comment je vais essayer
d'expliquer tout ça,
mes amis ?
Alors,
une réponse très basique,
je pense être impossible
le fait de croire
que tous les dilemmes
d'univers,
tous les problèmes,
tous les drames des personnes,
toute la dépression,
toute la tristesse,
toute la recherche
que nous avons,
soyons-nous chrétiens
ou pas chrétiens,
pour avoir une vie
un peu mieux,
un peu...
pour réussir dans la vie.
Je pense que c'est
vraiment, vraiment impossible
que tout ça
soit devenu
juste de l'évolution
d'une espèce.
C'est très basique,
très simple,
c'est ça que je suis
en fait,
je sais,
il y a plusieurs choses
derrière tout ça,
mais pour moi,
c'est tout simplement
impossible
que l'hasard
puisse créer
une complexité
telle que nous avons,
une vie telle
que nous avons
et surtout la recherche
de quelque chose
qui n'est parfois pas
du tout l'évolution.
Je trouve tout simplement
pas possible
et c'était comme ça
que je me suis converti
parce que moi,
je me suis posé des questions
avant de me convertir.
J'avais mes parents
chrétiens,
mais moi,
il faut me poser
ces questions.
Est-ce que je suis
chrétien ou pas?
Aujourd'hui,
je suis pasteur
et avant,
j'avais honte
de dire
que mes parents,
mon père,
il était pasteur
à l'école.
J'ai raconté ça
pendant l'ébranche
le mois dernier.
J'avais honte
quand mes amis
étaient en train
de dire
qu'est-ce que ton père
et qu'est-ce qu'il fait
de la vie
et mes amis
ils avaient
mon père est avocat,
mon père est un homme d'affaires
et là,
il venait vers moi.
Mon père,
il était pasteur
et toi,
Gustavo,
qu'est-ce que ton père
avait?
Alors là,
j'essaie de changer
de sujet.
J'avais honte
et aujourd'hui,
je suis devenu un pasteur.
C'est bizarre ça
et là,
c'était après avoir
plusieurs questions.
Certains,
je les ai faits.
Bon,
si je pense comme ça,
quand je pense
que le bonheur
et le plaisir infini
peuvent être trouvés,
quand je pense
qu'il faut,
qu'il doit avoir
un créateur,
ça me semble
plus raisonnable
le fait de,
s'il y a un créateur,
la solution,
la cause
et la réponse
s'y trouvent
quand on cherche,
quand on trouve
le créateur.
Ça va être plus simple,
plus raisonnable
de penser comme ça.
On ne parle pas
de la Bible
par l'instant.
On parle de quelque chose
qui est derrière,
mais si on ne comprend pas ça,
on n'arrive même pas
à croire que la Bible
elle est vraie.
Et d'accord.
OK.
Bon.
Et là,
c'est à chacun de nous
de croire au pas.
Je ne peux pas,
mais pas du tout,
je ne peux pas
mettre ça dans vos cœurs.
Je ne peux pas arriver
jusqu'au point
de dire,
voilà,
c'est ça que je crois.
Voici ma vie,
voici notre église,
voici ce que nous prêchons,
voici ce que nous croyons.
Mais c'est à vous,
chacun de vous,
de réfléchir à ça
et de se poser cette question,
est-ce que ça c'est vrai
pour moi,
mais vraiment vrai?
Pourquoi je suis en train
de suivre ça?
Bon.
si nous disons oui
à cette question,
c'est pas directement,
elle ne nous ramène pas
directement à la Bible.
Pourquoi?
Parce que,
ça me remet
à une deuxième question,
en fait.
Pourquoi,
parmi beaucoup de religions,
je dois baser
ma confiance
sur Dieu des chrétiens?
D'accord,
je crois que Dieu existe,
je t'avoue.
C'est bien.
Peut-être qu'il existe.
Mais,
pourquoi je dois dire
il y a plusieurs religions,
il y a plusieurs personnes
en train de parler des dieux?
Pourquoi je dois baser
ma confiance
au Dieu des chrétiens?
Au lieu du Dieu des bouddhistes,
au lieu du Dieu des hindouistes,
des musulmans.
Pourquoi le Dieu des chrétiens?
Pourquoi je dois choisir
ce Dieu
comme mon Dieu?
Parce que là,
on trouve une bonne partie
de la population
qui croit,
et qui croit
que Dieu existe.
mais,
pas tout à fait
le même Dieu,
la même chose.
Et encore une fois,
et c'est pour ça
qu'on va aller plus loin
ce mois,
parce que si on parle
de la Bible avant,
on doit parler de ça,
il faut qu'on se pose
cette question.
Mais,
très clairement,
comme on est en train
de faire ici,
ah,
ce n'est pas une chose
qu'on doit faire à l'église
parce que ça peut nous poser
des questions
qu'on va se douter.
Ça,
c'est génial.
La doute,
elle est absolument nécessaire.
La question,
elle est absolument nécessaire
si on essaie
de vivre une église
en train de cacher
les choses,
les problèmes,
les choses un peu plus lourdes
à comprendre,
pour moi,
ce n'est pas une bonne église,
ce n'est pas une bonne communauté.
Et c'est pour ça
qu'on est direct.
C'est pour ça
que moi,
je suis direct.
Parce qu'il faut
qu'on arrive
à comprendre ça.
Alors,
ma réponse,
encore une fois,
elle va se baser
dans deux choses.
C'est quoi
le centre de la Bible?
Le centre de la Bible,
il se trouve
dans une personne,
la personne de Jésus-Christ.
La Bible chrétienne,
elle prend Jésus
comme le centre
de cette parole.
C'est lui
le centre de la Bible.
Et là,
pour savoir
si on va croire
que cette Bible
a raison,
qu'on doit suivre
ce Dieu des chrétiens,
il faut voir
pourquoi il y a
un Dieu des chrétiens.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
chrétien?
Voilà,
ce sont des personnes
qui suivent Jésus-Christ.
Et ça,
c'est simple pour moi.
Non,
c'est pas simple.
Pardon,
parce que c'est pas
de tout simple.
Il a gagné ma confiance
avec plusieurs choses,
avec son autorité,
son amour,
son pouvoir.
Et je vois ça
dans la Bible,
elle-même,
mais je vois ça
en dehors
de la Bible.
Parce que comme
je vous ai expliqué
tout à l'heure,
je suis quelqu'un
qui essaie
de questionner,
de poser des questions.
Et je suis aussi
allé dans le côté
historique
de cette chose.
Pour voir
si Jésus,
donc la Bible parle,
donc la Bible relate,
est un peu le même Jésus.
Donc,
les personnes
qui étaient en train
d'étudier l'histoire,
ils sont en train
de relater.
Moi,
j'ai fait ça.
et je ne vois pas
du tout un souci
en train de faire
un problème
de faire ça.
J'ai dû faire ça
pour moi-même.
Parce que,
surtout si je suis pasteur
aujourd'hui,
si je prêche une chose,
si je parle d'une chose
que je ne crois pas
forcément,
ce n'est même pas la peine.
Et je vous encourage
à sortir ici
avec votre tête
en train de brûler.
Parce qu'il faut
qu'on se pose ces questions.
Soyons-nous chrétiens
ou pas ?
Alors,
pour moi,
le Christ des chrétiens,
Jésus,
il est incomparable
parce qu'il a vécu
plusieurs choses,
mais plusieurs choses
qui n'ont aucune autre figure,
aucun autre Dieu
ou personnalité
dans les religions
n'a pu vivre.
Et là,
dans la Bible,
on a plusieurs choses.
Il était en train
de prêcher sur la mûre,
il était en train
d'enseigner les personnes
à honorer Dieu
avec notre cœur.
Il est en train
de parler contre l'hypocrisie.
de parler,
de dédier son temps
aux enfants,
de bénir les enfants.
Il n'a pas fait
une séparation
entre les adultes,
les castes,
les choses comme ça.
Toutes les personnes,
les Juifs
et même les autres,
ils faisaient partie
de son royaume.
Il était en train
de guérir,
il était en train
de parler
avec des prostituées.
Ce n'était pas
une chose assez simple,
même dans notre jeu
d'aujourd'hui.
le fait de sortir,
de parler à une personne
pas très bien vue
dans la société,
c'est quelque chose
de pas évident.
Il était en train
de parler avec les SDF,
il a nettoyé
le pied de ses disciples
pendant qu'ils étaient
ses disciples.
Il a fait plusieurs choses
dans la Bible.
Et même quand ses disciples
ont rejeté Jésus
tel qu'il était,
il était là-bas
en train de les aimer,
de faire ça.
D'accord,
Gustavo,
mais ça c'est drôle
parce que tu es en train
de marcher un cirque.
Tu es en train
de dire que
est-ce qu'on doit
croire à la Bible
mais tu prends
la Bible elle-même
pour décrire Jésus
et tu penses
que ça suffit?
Non,
je ne suis pas en train
de marcher un cirque.
Ça c'est ce que
la Bible nous dit
et quand on voit
dans les études historiques,
dans les études
des personnes
qui ont parlé
de Jésus,
il était vraiment
semblable à ça.
on ne parle pas
du pouvoir spirituel,
on essaie
de supprimer
cette partie
par l'instant
et on dit
juste le caractère.
Et là,
j'ai dit
ah,
d'accord,
ça c'est vrai
au moins,
ça c'est quelque chose
qui a existé.
D'accord,
il était vraiment
comme ça,
mais ok,
là ça pourrait être
une personne
comme toutes les autres,
une bonne personne,
une personne qui a fait
des bénévoles.
Bon,
guérir c'est quelque chose
assez différent,
mais bon,
d'accord.
Mais non,
l'histoire,
elle nous raconte,
elle nous montre
un Jésus
assez différent
de toutes les autres.
Une personne
qui est venue
pour casser
le système
qui existait
à l'époque
et qui a vraiment
coupé l'histoire
en deux parties,
qui a vraiment
vécu plusieurs choses.
Ok,
d'accord.
Là,
jusqu'à là,
entre guillemets,
tout va bien.
Je ne crois pas
que Dieu existe,
je ne crois pas
que Jésus peut être,
même les Jésus historiques,
les Jésus
que l'Église
allait en train de parler
sont à peu près
la même personne,
mais
il faut se poser
une troisième question.
Ça va nous remettre,
ça va nous provoquer
une troisième question.
Il faut qu'on
se pose cette question.
Qu'est-ce que je pense
moi-même
de ce Jésus ?
On ne parle pas
de la Bible
par l'instant,
mais si on ne croit pas
que Jésus
pourrait être
vraiment quelqu'un
qui est au-delà
de la naturalité,
hors du naturel,
on va laisser tomber
la Bible,
parce que la Bible,
elle existe
pour nous parler
de tout ça.
D'abord,
avant même de lire,
avant même
de se poser la question,
avant même d'essayer
de comprendre
plus de détails,
il faut qu'on puisse
baser nos vies
sur tout ça.
Quelle est la troisième question ?
Qu'est-ce que je pense
de Jésus ?
moi-même
Est-ce qu'il existe ?
Est-ce qu'il n'existe pas ?
Est-ce que tout ça,
c'est vraiment
un grand mensonge ?
Est-ce que ça
pourrait être réel ?
On commence
l'année 2014
en train d'aller
directement
dans la base.
Parce que si on n'a
pas une bonne base,
je ne parle pas
de nouveaux chrétiens.
J'ai connu
plusieurs personnes
dans le milieu chrétien
qui avaient des postes
dans des églises,
qui avaient des choses
qui étaient en train
de travailler
comme des malades
pour les églises
et qui n'avaient pas
vraiment la certitude
de croire
que ça,
c'est vrai.
Et ça,
ce n'est pas la peine,
mes amis.
Nous sommes en train
d'établir une communauté
et dans une communauté,
il faut avoir
la réciprocité
et aussi la collectivité.
Si nous sommes en train
de cacher
des vérités
tellement importantes
et si nous sommes
en train de dire
il faut croire
à ça,
point,
sans discuter
des choses comme ça,
ce n'est pas la peine.
Alors,
ma troisième question,
j'ai commencé
à essayer
de répondre
à cette question.
Et là,
j'ai pris
deux schémas différents,
deux possibilités.
Bon,
soit
Jésus,
il a vraiment existé,
soit tout ça
est vrai,
est correct,
soit il était vraiment
le fils des dieux,
il a fait tout ça
qu'on a entendu,
je peux donner
ma vie à Jésus,
soit
quelqu'un d'autre
a inventé cette histoire.
Et j'ai commencé
avec ma tête
sociologue,
anthropologue,
voilà,
machin,
à me poser ces questions.
Et là,
j'ai commencé
à dire,
d'accord,
disons que
quelqu'un a inventé
toute cette histoire,
disons que ça,
c'est vrai
et que Jésus,
il n'a pas existé.
Ou sinon,
qu'il a existé à Jésus
parce que sinon,
même les personnes
sont en train
d'étudier l'histoire
et parce qu'ils ont trouvé
Jésus,
ils ont trouvé tout ça.
Disons que Jésus,
c'était tout simplement
une personne
comme moi
et quelqu'un
a inventé
toute cette histoire,
il a choisi Jésus,
voilà,
le fils de Maria
et Joseph
pour être le personnage
de cette histoire.
Et là,
j'ai commencé
à avoir la possibilité
de faire marcher
cette histoire.
Est-ce que vous avez
déjà essayé
d'inventer une histoire?
Une histoire,
une fausse histoire,
mais de faire semblant
que c'est vrai.
Ça a duré
combien de temps?
En plus,
pour combien de personnes?
Il y a
une expression
et je suis complètement
d'accord.
On peut
faire semblant
qu'une chose
est vraie
pendant beaucoup
de temps
pour
peu de personnes.
On peut faire
semblant
qu'une chose
est vraie
pendant
peu de temps
pour plusieurs
personnes.
Mais on ne peut
jamais faire semblant
qu'une chose
est vraie
pour beaucoup
de temps
pour plusieurs
personnes.
J'ai déjà
vécu ça.
on a eu
une expérience
au Brésil
dans le domaine
du business.
C'est terrible.
Ma femme,
elle était associée
avec une personne.
Ils ont créé
une société.
Je ne vais pas raconter
toute l'histoire,
mais la personne,
elle a inventé
une histoire,
une drôle d'histoire
qui nous a donné
beaucoup de soucis
au niveau
de l'argent,
la finance,
tout ça.
Et elle a fait
tout ça
à cause de son mari
parce que son mari
avait une ex-épouse
et elle n'avait pas
envie de donner
l'argent de son mari
à son ex-épouse.
Bref,
c'était horrible.
Mais c'était horrible.
Elle inventait
des clients,
elle inventait
des services,
des vies,
elle inventait
des chemins.
Mais horrible.
Et pendant
quatre mois,
elle a réussi,
mais elle a très bien
réussi à cacher
tout ça.
Et vous vous rendez
compte que,
par exemple,
c'était une organisation
qui travaillait
dans l'événementiel,
l'événementiel.
et là,
il fallait faire
des choses.
Par exemple,
il y avait une fête
à organiser.
Il fallait faire
des t-shirts
décorés,
des cadeaux,
surprises
qu'on allait donner
aux amis,
des invités,
des choses comme ça.
Ils ont tout produit.
Elle a fait en sorte
que c'était
tellement vrai,
mais du coup,
c'était pas vrai.
Et après,
elle prenait
les choses
et elle cachait
dans sa cave
pour qu'on puisse
penser à la fête.
Voilà,
c'était passé la fête,
c'était bien.
C'était bien,
oui,
super bien,
c'était tranquille.
Et pendant quatre mois,
elle a pu organiser
une histoire,
une drôle d'histoire
et elle a pu vraiment
faire beaucoup
de confusion.
Et là,
on parle de trois familles.
C'était ma famille,
sa famille à elle
et la famille
de Dalila.
On a tous,
nous tous,
on croyait vraiment
que ça,
c'était vrai.
Elle était vraiment,
vraiment à fond.
Quatre mois plus tard,
ça se cassait,
tout ça se cassait.
Et là,
c'était horrible,
c'était horrible.
Et là,
je me demande comment.
Parce que c'est encore
plus difficile pour moi
de croire
qu'une personne
a pu inventer
cette histoire
et a pu tenir
pendant 2000 ans
que le fait
de cette histoire,
est-ce que cette histoire
est vraie ?
C'est plus difficile
pour moi
de croire
qu'une personne
a pu inventer
tout ça,
a pu,
même dans l'époque
de Jésus,
a pu convaincre
les disciples
à écrire des choses
sur lui
alors que ce n'était
pas vraiment lui.
Et même après,
elle a pu convaincre
toute une génération
à construire
toute une église
qui parle de lui
et qui donne
sa vie à lui
et des gens
en train de mourir
pour lui
alors qu'il n'existait pas.
Franchement,
franchement,
là,
je craquais en fait.
À ce moment-là,
je me suis dit
il faut sortir
de naturel
avec ma tête
de sociologue,
machin,
bref,
il faut sortir
de ça,
il faut poser
cette question.
Est-ce que
je crois
à tout ça
ou pas ?
J'ai fermé
mes yeux
pendant plusieurs jours,
plusieurs semaines
et j'ai commencé
à demander
à Dieu
lui-même
est-ce que
tu existes
ou quoi ?
Mais c'est vrai,
je ne rigole pas
parce que mon père
il était pasteur,
mon oncle
ils y sont toujours,
toute ma famille
chrétienne
super engagée
à l'église
et moi avec
beaucoup de questions.
Voilà,
je dis mais attendez,
arrête.
Dieu,
c'est moi et toi là.
Est-ce que ça,
c'est vrai ou pas ?
Je vous invite
à commencer cette année.
On est au mois de février
parce que c'est
encore plus drôle
pour moi
et là,
je parle plutôt
pour les chrétiens.
Si vous êtes chrétien,
c'est pour nous-mêmes,
pour moi
parce que je suis
chrétien aussi.
C'est que c'est
le plus drôle,
c'est que
c'est très basique
ce que tu es en train
de raconter,
Gustave,
c'est très basique.
Je suis chrétien,
ça fait longtemps
que j'entends,
tu vas parler de la Bible.
Je sais tout ça,
allez,
ah non,
je pourrais être
dans une autre église
ce matin
parce que
c'est très basique.
D'accord,
je vous demande
une chose
parce que
j'aime se poser
cette question.
Pourquoi alors
que c'est très basique
ça ?
Si nous croyons
vraiment à ça,
si nous croyons
vraiment que Dieu
il existe,
que tout ça,
c'est vrai,
machin,
pourquoi nous sommes
en train de donner
2%,
3%,
4%,
moins de 10%
de nos emplois
de temps,
de nos vies,
de nos priorités
à ces dieux-là.
Ça c'est fort,
pour moi c'est fort
parce que
si je crois
que Dieu existe
et ça,
il a,
c'est tout,
quand je parle de ça,
là,
à ces moments,
quand je suis en train
de vous parler,
je suis en train
de réfléchir
et je suis en train
de me dire
qu'est-ce que je suis
en train
de faire de ma vie ?
Quelles sont
mes priorités ?
Mon emploi de temps,
il est où ?
Il est basé où ?
Si je crois vraiment
à ça,
à cette histoire,
est-ce que ça suffit
ce qu'il se rend
en train de faire ?
Est-ce que ça suffit
ce qu'il se rend
en train de vivre ?
La répentance,
elle a gagné
un contexte
beaucoup plus intéressant
pour moi.
Plusieurs personnes
parlent de la répentance,
voilà,
quand on pêche,
on doit se répentir,
quand on fait des bêtises,
on doit se répentir
et toujours la répentance
c'était comme ça
pour moi.
Par contre,
la répentance pour moi
aujourd'hui,
elle va beaucoup
au-delà de ça.
La répentance pour moi,
c'est toujours
quand je pense
que Dieu peut exister,
que ça c'est vrai.
Je suis toujours
en train de me répentir,
pas forcément
pour ce que je fais,
voilà,
des bêtises,
des péchés,
oui,
ça aussi,
parce que je ne suis pas
super belle.
On est tous
des êtres humains
et comme je dis
au départ,
la vie,
elle n'est pas toujours
belle et on doit
toujours se répentir
par rapport à ça,
mais à part ça,
je ne suis plus
en train de me répentir
dans le fait de,
je pourrais être
en train de faire
beaucoup plus
et je ne suis pas.
Je pourrais être
en train de vivre
beaucoup plus
et je ne suis pas.
Ma répentance aujourd'hui,
elle est beaucoup plus
dans ce sens-là.
Si je crois
que tout ça est vrai,
je dois
faire attention
à la Bible.
Alors ça,
c'est juste
le premier dimanche
de ces mois
parce que pour parler
de la Bible,
il faut parler
de tout ça avant.
Sinon,
on va commencer
dans le deuxième
match,
c'est ça,
le match,
et il faut commencer
au reste,
je sais,
pas au premier état.
Il faut qu'on se pose
cette question,
nous tous.
Oui,
mais je crois
tout ça,
d'accord,
pose-la quand même.
Il faut qu'on se pose
cette question
parce que
si on comprend
bien tout ça,
on va sortir d'ici
et on va vivre
nos vies
avec l'envie
de lire la Bible
trois fois par jour
et trois heures
par heure.
Parce que
c'est tout simplement
si je crois
que Dieu existe,
que Dieu est tout
ce que je suis
en train d'entendre
dans des églises,
si je crois
que Dieu est vraiment
puissant,
si je crois
que Dieu
se monte
à travers sa parole,
si je crois
que sa parole
est la Bible,
si je crois
à tout ça,
je dois plonger
vraiment
dans la Bible.
Je dois lire
vraiment tous les jours.
Mais je dois connaître
cette chose
parce que
tous les pasteurs
que j'ai entendus,
que j'ai pleuré
peut-être un jour,
voilà,
toutes les personnes
qui m'ont dit
quelque chose
qui s'était vraiment fort,
c'était vraiment
important pour moi,
toutes ces personnes,
je vous assure,
si elles ont dit
une chose
qui est vraiment valable,
cette chose
se trouve dans la Bible.
Si elle ne se trouve
pas dans la Bible,
pour nous les chrétiens,
ça ne marche pas.
Alors,
je vous invite
à sortir d'ici
avec votre tête
en train de brûler
et de se dire
je dois lire la Bible,
mais pas pour une obligation.
On n'est pas obligé,
jamais on va obliger
les personnes
qui sont en train
de devenir responsables
pour le département
à l'église,
elles me connaissent
un peu mieux
et elles sont au courant
que j'ai du mal
avec des règles trop
et je dois avoir
un peu plus de règles,
je sais,
je parle ça
à mes amis
que cette fin de l'année
plusieurs amis
m'ont dit
Moustaphe,
tu dois mettre
certaines règles en plus
parce que ça va marcher mieux
et c'est vrai
que ça va marcher mieux,
je suis d'accord,
mais c'est difficile
pour moi
et surtout l'obligation
je déteste l'obligation
et je n'aimerais pas
vous obliger
à faire quoi que ce soit,
je ne suis pas du tout
contre les programmes
de on va lire la Bible
entière
pendant une année,
je ne suis pas du tout
contre ça,
si vous êtes en train
de faire ça,
continuez,
mais je n'ai pas trop
l'obligation
quand on n'a pas du tout
envie de lire,
quand on ne comprend rien,
quand on lit juste
pour dire qu'on lit,
pour marquer le,
voilà,
c'est bon,
je n'aime pas trop ça,
j'aime le fait
d'aimer,
de prendre le plaisir
dans une chose,
pourquoi j'aime la musique ?
Pourquoi j'aime toujours
étudier la musique ?
Parce que la musique
elle est infinie,
parce que la musique
elle me plaît tellement
que j'ai envie
d'aller plus loin
en tant que musicien,
toujours,
et si je pense
au moins comme ça
par rapport à Dieu,
je dois penser
la même chose,
alors,
je vous assure,
moi,
que la Bible
elle peut devenir
une essence
extraordinaire
pour vous.
Si vous êtes en train
de chercher
des réponses,
si vous êtes en train
de chercher des choses,
de chercher
des dilemmes,
des problèmes,
des frustrations
que vous avez,
parce que parfois
on l'a,
si vous avez besoin
que votre âme
soit restaurée,
personne d'autre
pour faire ça.
Moi,
je ne peux pas faire ça.
Un pasteur,
il n'a pas le pouvoir
de guérir une personne.
Un pasteur,
je dis ça tout à l'heure,
il n'est pas un guru
spirituel.
La personne qu'on va
appeler,
pasteur,
qu'est-ce que je dois faire ?
Je vais me marier,
j'ai deux filles,
et alors celle-là,
elle est plus jolie
que celle-ci,
mais qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Je dois me marier.
Je ne sais pas.
C'est à toi
de décider.
Je rigole.
Un pasteur,
il est toujours là
pour donner des conseils.
Ça,
ça fait partie.
Mais on n'est pas
des gurus.
Je ne sais pas.
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Vas-y.
Non,
mais ce n'est pas comme ça.
Parce que la Bible,
elle nous dit,
on doit se renseigner
avec nos amis.
Mais soit la paix de Dieu,
l'arbitre
de nos décisions.
Que la parole de Dieu,
là,
c'est dans le livre
des Colossiens,
si je dis ça,
c'est joli,
parce que ce n'est pas moi,
c'est la Bible,
encore une fois.
Si on enlève la Bible
du pasteur Gustavo,
c'est fini.
C'est vrai.
Je n'ai rien à dire d'autre.
La Bible,
elle nous dit
que la parole soit riche
dans vos cœurs.
Soit riche.
Alors,
on va essayer de vivre ce mois
en train de parler
de la Bible,
en train de vous donner
pas mal d'idées.
La deuxième partie
de cette histoire,
et là,
je vous encourage aussi,
on va lancer
un projet
qui s'appelle,
c'est un cours,
on a fait un cours
sur la vision
de notre église,
on va refaire ce cours
pour les personnes
qui sont en train d'arriver,
mais on va avoir
un autre cours aussi
qui va parler
de l'autorité
de la Bible,
de Dieu,
tout ça.
Et là,
on va parler beaucoup plus
sur l'autorité biblique.
On n'a pas besoin
de défendre
des choses comme ça
parce que finalement,
quand je me suis mis
à prier,
qu'est-ce que ça se passait?
Et là,
je dois dire ça
parce que c'est comme ça
que ça se passe.
Dieu,
il s'est réveillé à moi.
Il s'est révélé à moi.
Je suis convaincu
que si vous n'avez pas
une expérience
avec Dieu,
personnelle,
vous pouvez rester
quelques années
dans une église.
Ça pourrait être
la meilleure église
de l'univers
avec la bonne musique,
le pastor qui prêche,
qui est bon
pour faire des blagues,
des choses comme ça,
qui est super intelligent,
voilà, machin,
avec des personnes sympathiques.
Au bout d'un moment,
vous allez vous fatiguer
de cette histoire
parce que ça ne vous parle pas.
Il faut couper ce chemin
qui peut être douloureux.
Il faut tout de suite
se poser cette question.
il faut tout de suite
dire,
Seigneur,
si tu existes,
quoi,
s'il te plaît,
je dois voir ça,
je dois cheminer sur ça.
Et c'est pour ça
que je vous encourage
de lire la Bible.
Parce que Dieu peut vous parler
à travers la Bible,
à travers plusieurs choses.
J'ai plein d'histoires
et je vais finir avec une histoire.
Une des personnes
la plus engagée
de mon église à Rio,
au Brésil,
était un monsieur
avec 60 ans.
Et c'est pour ça
qu'une des choses
qui me fait régler
la santé d'une église,
pour moi,
une église,
la bonne santé d'une église,
elle se voit
quand on a plusieurs générations
dans cette église.
C'est pour ça
qu'alors que j'aime
un type de musique,
un type de chanson,
j'aime mon style,
j'ai ma chanson préférée,
j'ai mon style préféré.
Mais quand on parle
d'un contexte
communautaire d'église,
moi, je suis quelqu'un
qui pense à plusieurs générations
parce que la santé d'une église,
pour moi,
se voit quand on a
plusieurs générations.
C'est tout de faire
une église
qui est pour les enfants,
qui est pour les jeunes,
qui est pour les ados,
qui est pour...
Je ne suis pas du tout...
Pas du tout dans...
Je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord
parce qu'une église,
elle se fait
parmi plusieurs générations.
Et alors,
en revenant à mon histoire,
ce monsieur,
il avait 60 ans,
il était super engagé
avec Dieu,
avec l'église.
Et là,
un jour,
j'arrive
dans sa maison
et je vois un livre
très, très, très vieux,
très ancien.
Et c'était cool
parce que Jonathan
m'a montré un livre
qui a 50 ans,
c'est ça,
à peu près 50 ans.
Et là,
ce livre,
il était vraiment,
il avait peut-être
même plus qu'une centaine
d'années.
Vraiment,
comme ça.
Et là,
c'était dans son armoire,
comme ça.
Là, on a un bar,
vous avez vu,
c'est cool,
après,
on peut faire
le café ici.
C'est simple,
c'est cool.
Et c'était comme ça,
c'était un livre
dans son armoire.
Et j'ai dit là,
comme je sais toujours
que quelqu'un me faisait
des questions,
« Ah,
les curieux,
c'est quoi ce livre-là ?
C'est assez différent. »
Et là,
je raconte cette histoire.
il a pris,
c'était une Bible.
Mais une Bible
comme je l'avais,
comme je n'avais jamais vue.
Vraiment,
vraiment ancienne,
de 200 ans,
quoi.
Et là,
il m'a dit,
« Tu sais,
cette Bible-là ? »
Je me suis converti
grâce à cette Bible-là.
Bien sûr qu'il rigolait,
c'était pas grâce au livre.
Et là,
je me dis,
« Mais raconte-moi cette histoire. »
Et d'accord,
mon,
comment on dit,
mon arrière-grand-père,
arrière-grand-père,
c'est ça ?
Mon arrière-arrière-grand-père,
il a trouvé cette Bible
dans une poubelle.
Et là,
il a pris cette Bible.
Il n'était pas
de tout chrétien.
Il ne connaissait pas
cette histoire d'église.
Voilà,
surtout parce qu'au Brésil,
on n'avait que l'église catholique
à l'époque,
voilà.
Et c'était très difficile
parce qu'à l'époque,
même pour avoir
une Bible portugais,
c'était bon,
bref.
Et là,
il a trouvé cette Bible
en portugais.
Il a commencé à la lire.
Et finalement,
il est tombé
sur l'histoire de Jésus.
Et finalement,
il commence à lire
et à lire
et il commence à voir
et après,
Jésus est mort.
Il a dit,
d'accord,
il était bien,
mais c'est dommage,
il est mort.
Mais il était tellement intrigué
qu'il a continué à lire
et après,
il a lu sur la résurrection
de Jésus.
trois jours plus tard,
pooh,
ce monsieur m'a dit,
ses parois,
elles ont enflammé
le cœur
de mon arrière-rière-grand-père.
Il est devenu,
il a beaucoup pleuré,
il s'est changé,
il s'est complètement
bouleversé
sa famille
et conséquemment,
ma famille.
Et aujourd'hui,
je suis là.
Je suis né
dans ce contexte,
mais c'était très clair,
très réel,
qui est pour moi,
le fait d'avoir mon expérience
était beaucoup plus simple
parce que je voyais
des choses très pratiques
dans ma famille.
La façon de vivre
l'évangile,
elle était vraiment là.
Pas tout simplement
la façon de parler
de l'évangile,
mais la façon de vivre.
Mon arrière-grand-père
a complètement changé
sa vie.
Et là,
mes amis,
c'est ça que je vous invite
à faire,
je vous encourage à faire,
à sortir d'ici.
Si vous êtes chrétien,
tant mieux.
Mais il faut penser
à cette question
que je me suis posée.
Si je crois
que c'est vrai,
combien de temps
je suis en train
de dédier à ça?
Si je crois
que ça,
c'est la chose
la plus importante
de ma vie,
comme on est en train
de chanter,
je t'adore,
ça c'est quoi?
J'ai fait très attention
à ce que j'ai dit.
à ce que je chante.
Sinon,
on est en train
de mentir,
même dans l'église.
Je t'adore,
je t'adore pas.
Il faut faire attention.
Mais pour que ça soit vrai,
il faut que chacun
de nous
puisse se poser
ses questions.
Et là,
on va parler de la Bible.
Parce que là,
la Bible,
elle va gagner
une valeur
beaucoup plus importante.
de la Bible.
...